Ukraїner
Експедиція
Галичина,
Львів
Громадська організація з'явилась 20 років тому.
Мета: заявити про свою національність...
[Микола Юрченко,
громадський активіст]
...зламати цей стереотип
і показувати людей,
які є представниками цієї національності.
Це такі самі звичайні люди,
як будь-якої іншої національності.
Є й багаті, є й бідні.
Є і добрі, і не дуже.
Це звичайні люди.
Для загальної статистики: ромів в Україні
зараз близько 300 тисяч.
Є декілька класифікацій ромів в Україні.
Є роми осідлі й інтегровані,
є просто осідлі.
Якщо брати по нашій території,
то у Львівській області це Дрогобич.
Вони компактно живуть.
І є мандруюючі,
трудові мігранти їх ще називають.
На Львівщині небагато мешкає.
Близько 700 людей.
Вони всі постійно тут живуть.
Всі мають документи.
Всі діти ходять до школи.
Інтегровані люди, вони розуміють,
що без цього зараз не можна жити.
Що то вже такий час, коли треба мати освіту.
У 2014-2016 рр. було стажування ромської молоді
в органах місцевого самоврядування.
Пілотний проект почався в 2014 році.
Тоді три наші студенти пішли до мерії.
Там вони проходили стажування у різних відділах.
Це окрема історія, їх не дуже хотіли брати.
І депутати ходили, і ми листи надсилали.
Але цікаве те, що наші чиновники у мерії
також змінили думку.
Чиновник каже: «Я собі уяви не мала,
як в мене тут буде сидіти циган
і на клавіатурі щось там робити.
Але через тиждень Володя
(вона його вже Володею називала)
виявився ціковою молодою людиною,
яка знає, що робити».
А на третьому тижні
вона запропонувала йому робоче місце.
Крім того, що це дає особистий кар'єрний ріст,
вони своїм прикладом
змінили думку багатьох людей.
Які потім приходили у свої родини і говорили:
«А роми ж можуть бути й у нас чиновниками,
і виконоувати якусь роботу».
І їм навіть давали дуже тяжку роботу
для того, щоб підвести: вони не справились.
Але вони справилися.
Вони все виконали й після цього
чиновники змінили дуже свою думку.
Це ми зараз говоримо, що це роми.
Але є перша назва: громадяни України.
Якщо влада не буде
піклуватися про своїх громадян,
то, звісно, виросте неосвічене покоління.
А, якщо брати Закарпаття,
то там мешкає близько 100 тисяч людей.
Це ж скільки з них там дітей.
Це великі ромські родини, де по 7-8 дітей.
І цим треба піклуватися.
Цей негатив відносно ромів
ми можемо зламати
тільки нашою освіченою молоддю.
Тому ми весь час
намагаємося співпрацювати з молоддю.
Освіта дає свій прогрес.
Чим більше буде молоді освіченої,
тим швидше ми покращемо інтеграцію ромів
в загальне суспільство
і зламаємо негативний стереотип.
Мене звати Іван Коржов, я львів'янин.
Я ром.
[Іван Коржов,
фахівець у сфері ІТ]
Навіть коли мені казали: промовчи, що ти ром,
а то мало шо, все ж таки ти світлий,
я навпаки, перше, що робив, коли заходив,
говорив: «Привіт! Я - ром».
Для мене це завжди був момент якоїсь боротьби.
Я завжди ставив це викликом.
І я не можу сказати,
що для мене це колись
чимось поганим закінчувалося.
Коли люди чують, що ти ром, вони кажуть:
«Слухай, а ти танцюєш? Співаєш?
А може погадати вмієш?»
І я такий: та нє, я проста людина, як і ви.
Я вчився у Львові у школі,
я вчився у Львові в інституті.
Яке гадати?
Співати я вмію, звісно.
Але це ж не значить,
що я маю співати при кожній зустрічі.
В мене було багато моментів у житті.
В мене був викладач, який мав таку цікаву фразу:
«Цигани є і зараз...
(це на лекції, щоб ви розуміли)
... якщо деякі з них такі, як ми їх звикли бачити,
просять на вулиці і на вокзалах,
то інші, більш панського вигляду, торгують наркотиками».
Я тоді був ще доволі молодий
і в мене були такі думки:
а до кого ж себе віднести?
Наркотиками не торгую, ні в кого нічого не прошу.
Що ж робити?
Я мав з ним доволі довгу розмову
і це, в принципі, було одним із стартів того,
що я почав займатися громадською діяльністю.
Вже коли я навчався в університеті,
ближче до закінчення,
ми мали декілька цікавих проектів.
В рамках одного з них відбувалося стажування
в органах місцевого самоврядування для ромів.
Я потрапив на роботу в міську раду.
Простажувався там успішно.
В якийсь момент допрацювався там
до начальника управління інформаційних технологій.
Було багато речей, які ми робили перші в Україні.
Певно, трошки дивно було чути,
що ром працює в управлінні ІТ,
ще й керівником якийсь час.
І при цьому робить якісь речі,
яких немає навіть в більших містах.
З того, чим я найбільше пишаюся,
з того, що працює,
це громадський бюджет Львова.
Такий, який він є зараз.
Це був мій дипломний проект
під час навчання в католицькому університеті.
В свій час, ми перші у Львові
дали можливість замовляти електроні послуги
через Bank-ID.
Ми перші у Львові почали
відкривати бюджет на різних платформах.
Наприклад, openbudget.in.ua.
Це було багато крутих речей, які насправді
у 2015-2016 роках
ми фактично вибудовували з нуля.
Ми їздили по різним конференціям,
шукали якісь класні ідеї.
І намагалися їх втілити у Львові.
Безкоштовно, що немало важливо.
Існує величезна купа стереотипів про нас.
Якщо ти ром, то маєш красти, гадати,
жебракувати або торгувати наркотиками.
Коли це чуєш один раз - смішно.
Другий раз вже не дуже смішно
На третій раз ти починаєш злитися.
А на четвертий просто перестаєш реагувати.
Повністю закриваєшся в цей кокон,
коли не реагуєш.
Ось тут і виникає найбільше непорозуміннь.
Я можу сказати, що проблема освіти,
як мінімум нашої,
вирішується постійно.
Я є членом національної відбіркової комісії
Ромського освітнього фонду.
Цей фонд останніх десять років
допомагає молодим ромам України та інших країн
здобувати освіту.
Я й сам був колись степендіантом цієї програми.
Я бачу зростаючу якість.
Людей, які хочуть здобути освіту.
Молодих ромів, в яких горять очі.
Які хочуть дійсно щось змінити навколо себе.
Я щиро вважаю, що саме в цих людях, в цих дітях,
в цій молоді
є той відсутній елемент, що зможе зв'язати
адекватну інтеграцію нас у суспільство
і суспільства в нас.
Я вважаю, що багато чого хорошого робиться.
І так і має продовжуватися.
Автор проекту: Богдан Логвиненко
Оператори: Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб
Продюсерка: Оля Шор
Режисер: Микола Носок